there was an air of hope and expectation
in this Ottawa sports bar ahead of
Canada's second round match against
switzerland everyone here wanted to see
their team's world cup journey continue
they have to win an order to keep like
the country's attention on the women's
tournament I hope that they get to the
next round after this and we can enjoy
some more great soccer it's gonna be a
tight game but Canada will pull through
passionate team Canadian spirit will
take us through but the first half
contained little to set pulses racing
the fans here had mixed feelings ahead
of the second half it was good but it
was intense they were a bit all over the
place so fingers crossed I get it
together for the second half well I
think they need to score because it's a
little scary going 00 into the second
half then the gold had been waiting for
finally came
really pretty good goal come on nobody
was expecting it was pretty good great
goal by jose a and they need to get
another one because i'm still nervous we
need another one we need another one
it's sooo close that second goal never
arrived and fans were kept on the edges
of their seats with their team holding
on to a slender lead but that lead was
enough and the final whistle left the
home fans in ecstasy
amazing I knew the girl win and they
pulled it through it was a great game
very stressful at the end but we pulled
through and I can't wait to see the next
one we're very proud Canadians here
number one gonna win well some of the
fans were already looking forward to the
quarterfinals most just wanted to
celebrate another win for their country
at their home tournament